[Musique]
salut en ce moment je réfléchis à pas
mal de choses oui ça m'arrive et je me
suis aperçu que ma dernière faq daté
d'exactement juillet 2016 on ne peut pas
vraiment dire que j'ai abusé du concept
dans cette vidéo j'ai quelque chose
d'important à vous dire et je me suis
dit que c'était une bonne occasion pour
mêler ça à vos questions je vous ai
demandé ce week-end sur facebook oui ça
existe encore et sur instagram si vous
vouliez me demander quelque chose et
voilà c'est ce qu'on va faire loïc non
c'est parce que tu penses
je voulais juste savoir comment tu vas
transférant moi ça va bien ouais bah
leurs génériques
[Musique]
c'est un peu le sujet de cette vidéo
j'ai passé le million d'abonnés sur
cette chaîne youtube à peu malgré moi et
je veux dire c'est sûrement le meilleur
truc qui me soit arrivée dans ma vie en
tout cas le plus fou et je me sens
physiquement soutenu par vous ensemble
on a vraiment fait des trucs de dingue
et à côté de ça une sorte de
responsabilité un peu bizarre qui s'est
installé dans mon contenu c'est à dire
que je peux plus faire de petites vidéos
un peu comme je faisais en 2016 tu vois
je sens que si je fais ça vous allez me
dire dans les commentaires s est passé
mon gars on en attend plus j'avais
d'ailleurs essayé en juillet 2010 est de
faire ça plus de vidéos sur des contenus
un petit peu plus court plus léger ça
devait durer deux mois
ça a duré trois semaines j'ai vite
arrêté j'ai lu compris le message et en
même temps je vous comprends c'est tout
à fait légitime
alors j'ai vraiment pris du temps pour
réfléchir à tout ça ça fait trois mois
que je suis dessus j'ai même organisé
des réunions brainstorm avec des amis de
youtube
je vous ai posé énormément de questions
à vous lors des dédicaces après mes
spectacles pour en tirer des conclusions
et savoir un peu parce que devenait
cette chaîne est ce que je devenais aux
six mois dans tout ça et surtout moi
avec vous regardez bien cette vidéo en
entier vous allez apprendre pas mal de
choses et peut-être des réponses à vos
questions d'ailleurs voici les trois
premières questions que je sélectionne
pour le côté un petit peu et facussé
celles qui sont le plus
première question de jacques saluer ce
que tu va pérenniser le format dans
lequel tu décrypte le langage non verbal
des personnalités publiques
alors j'ai pris ce message parce qu'il
symbolise pas mal de messages sur la
question donc oui je vais continuer à
faire d amélie ça c'est certain mais je
vais pas tomber dans des pièges un peu
grossier jorge j'ai reçu des centaines
mais des milliers de messages pour
savoir si j'allais faire une vidéo d'
analyse sur le reportage living
neverland vous allez sur michael ça je
vais pas le faire je veux pas le faire
parce qu'il ya plein de choses comme ça
que je ne peux pas faire
déjà parce que ça a été monté comme un
reportage ya sûrement eu d'erytech c'est
pas comme une conversation en fait non
coupée avec des réactions france où la
personne ne s'attend pas aux questions
là on sait pas si c'est du jeu pas du
jeu je peux retenir l'enfer est à la
limite j'ai envie de vous dire je vais
pas m'amuser à n'y a analysé pas abuser
parce que c'est très bizarre comme a
analysé la souffrance de personnes
pendant quatre heures parce que c'est ça
ce reportage donc je suis personne en
fait pour essayer de déceler quelque
chose alors que si ça se trouve la
personne ça fait trois fois cas raconte
l'histoire du coup il ya moins de signes
de vérité et dire ce serait mentir tous
cas pas cool donc voilà je vais
continuer à faire des analyses mais
jamais sur des enjeux grossier juste
pour faire début parce que je sais que
cette vidéo là après ou
de vue sort de la chaîne mais je vais
pas faire ça parce que c'est pas bien ce
qui est gestion suivante de arthur batut
de relancer des objectifs ou comme faire
une vidéo par jour pendant un an est ce
que tu vas refaire des live
ok je croyais que c'était des livres non
cd live des objectifs ou je crois un
j'ai juste l'impression que j'en ai tout
le temps en fait avoir lancé une chasse
au trésor où il ya vraiment dit vrai
diamant a gagné cela forme d'un livre
c'est un objectif ou avoir fait la
mémoire il boxe est un objectif ou avoir
fait l'olympia ce un objectif ou tout tu
vois même la vidéo pour le million
d'abonnés c'était un objectif un peu
dingue
donc en fait des objectifs ou c'est un
peu mon moteur ça tu vas cg13 stimuler à
chaque fois par la nouveauté par le défi
par le challenge
mais quand c'est nouveau c'est pour
cette bonne raison que je referai jamais
quelque chose que j'ai déjà fait refaire
une vidéo par jour pendant un an
ça rime à rien en fait j'ai déjà vécu ça
c'est déjà un challenge que j'ai
accompli que j'ai relevé donc je vois
pas trop l'intérêt de leur faire ça me
stimule rep ah et puis je pense mais ce
ne serait pas une bonne idée des live je
continue à enfermer les live c'est
toujours en sauvage et éphémère tiers
sauvage c'est à dire c'est pas prévu je
peux le dessiner genre une heure avant
éphémère c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
replay ce qui nous donne une vraie
liberté durant le live
la seule manière de pas rater les live
c'est de me suivre sur un stade parce
que je les annonces toujours sur un star
et d'activer la cloche sur lui troisième
question à quand le casse tête de fabien
olicard quitte à le faire en
collaboration avec un ingé dit guy est
ce que tu aimerais en faire alors je
pense vraiment qu'il aura jamais de
castets de moi alors faut jamais dire
jamais mais dans le sens où je ne pense
pas que je suis compétent a imaginé un
casse tête c'est pour ça que je me fais
toujours surprendre par eux parce que
j'ai pas cette créativité la créativité
là j'ai plein de qualités sûrement dans
la vie mais j'ai pas celle ci et je n'ai
pas la prétention de la voix donc je ne
vois même pas comment imaginer un casse
tête est alors après comme on réalisait
etc
oui là il faudrait des ingénieurs des
mecs qui savent vraiment bien faire moi
je ne sais pas faire ça donc je sais pas
et par contre je sais qu'ici on
attendait une vidéo ici le truc avec le
policier c'était la logique
c'était cette porc story donc voilà je
pense pas réaliser un jour un casse-tête
en tout cas c'est pas un truc que
j'aimerais faire j'aime les résoudre
j'adore ça j'adore qu'on m'envoie des
hypers originaux des jolies des
complexes ou des malins tu vois mais je
joue
ouais c'est pas un but en soi pour moi
de faire un casse tête je pense pas être
bon là dedans s'il ya bien un truc que
vous me dites en grande majorité après
les spectacles c'est la phrase suivante
je pensais pas que c'était aussi drôle
et aussi chaud alors bon show spectacle
c'est pas la chaleur de la salle
c'est un super compliment en soi et en
même temps c'est terrible pour moi
d'entendre ça parce que je me dis mais
attends ça fait huit ans que je suis sur
scène huit ans que je suis en tournée
c'est mon troisième spectacle ça a
toujours été la forme d'humour comment
ça se fait que ce soit 6 1 2 3 comment
ça se fait que ce soit si surprenant
c'est pas simple à dire un essai essaie
de le dire je vois c'est pas simple donc
je me suis ok je vais leur poser la
question à chaque fois que vous me le
dites maintenant l'heure des dédicaces
je vous demande est votre réponse elle
est incroyable c'est fabien en vidéo
tu n'es pas drôle vous avez raison c'est
une réalité je suis pas vraiment drôle
en vidéo et je comprend du coup ça
puisse être surprenant et ça me ferait
ça m'emmerde un petit peu quoi tu vois
de me dire mais quand ça se fait que je
suis si différent apparemment en
apparence sur les vidéos et les
spectacles j'ai réfléchi à ça aussi les
15000 personnes qui sont venues voir le
nouveau spectacle depuis septembre
dernier ils peuvent en témoigner dans
les commentaires je c'est drôle sur
scène je fais pas mal d'un produit ou
d'un plat j'adore faire ça mais par
contre c'est aussi d'ailleurs pour ça
que j'ai toujours été programmé dans
l'état de l'humour là les festivals
d'humour tout ça mais je sais pas être
drôle face à une caméra je sais pas
faire des blagues sans public un truc
froid comme ça j'ai essayé de le faire
vraiment je vous jure ça rend pas ouf
alors fort de tous âges et j'ai dû
prendre des décisions trouver des
solutions je vais vous dire tout ça dans
la suite mais avant je vais répondre à
trois autres questions de la rfec
question de sébastien serais-tu
intéressé pour faire un rôle dans une
série ou un film mais bien sûr non
blague à part way j'adore qu'on
me sèye de m'imaginer en employant dans
des trucs différents de ce que je sais
faire c'est pour ça que je fais pas que
du mentalisme en permanence parce que je
veux pas me sentir enfermés là dedans en
fait c'est ma passion c'est ma
spécificité mais ça ne veut pas dire que
je dois faire que ça que ça que ça tout
le temps là en ce moment je suis en
train de tourner une web série pour une
autre chaîne j'adore ce à quoi si un
jour on me propose un rôle au cinéma un
tout petit rôle dans un truc à rien à
voir mais [ __ ] je serai au top de ma
life parce que ce serait une nouvelle
expérience est ce que j'aime c'est
essayer des choses dans plein de
domaines
prochaine question question de mythes ne
la veux je pense que c'est valentin à
l'envers en l'écrivant différemment
comptes tu faire des vidéos sur
l'astrophysique associé au mentalisme
comme dans son spectacle singularité
alors oui ça c'est un truc vous le savez
pas forcément mais je suis vraiment
grand passionné d'astrophysique et du
coup j'en parle dans les spectacles
c'est pour ça qu'ils s'appellent
singularité pour leur singularité
initiale tout ça mais j'en ai vraiment
jamais parlé sur la chaîne et ben il est
temps que ça cesse
je compte faire des vidéos là dessus
alors pas forcément le mélangeant au
mentalisme mais en même temps c'est ces
sachets des big bang dans la tête quand
tu vois d'astrophysique des trous noirs
la matière noire énergie noire
j'aimerais parler tout ça là sous le
compte faire une vidéo aussi sur la
terre plate j'aimerais vraiment en
parler donc la semaine prochaine je
pense tourner ça donc oui je vais
commencer à ouvrir la chaîne à tout ce
que j'aime
et pas juste centré sur le mentalisme en
ligue 1 prochaine question c'est kevin
c'est hyper long elle le fait bien
comment vois-tu ton évolution sur
youtube ça va redémarrer ton aventure
pourtant plaisir perso avec une vidéo
par jour pendant un an
tu continues à multiplier les créations
sur plusieurs supports spectacle hip
vidéo je me suis dit avoir entendu dire
que tu ne passeras clairement pas d'avis
sur youtube et a dépassé le million
d'abonnés
je suis plus un youtuber qu'autre chose
comment tu vois ça alors ok il ya plein
de trucs c'est hyper intéressant
déjà tu dis que je multiplie les
créations en dehors de youtube spectacle
libre et où il faut vraiment pas oublier
que à la base mon métier c'est d'être
sur scène en fait c'est bien avant
youtube avant youtube je remplissais
déjà des salles de 500 à 800 places en
tournée c'est pas rien tu vois ce que je
veux dire donc c'est pas après youtube
que j'ai fait ça ensuite oui quand en
fait quand je dis je passerai pas
clairement pas ma vie sur youtube
jacques dor youtube j'adore faire les
vidéos mais j'y passe pas ma vie pour
tout dire c'est ce qui me prend le moins
de temps dans ma vie c'est les vidéos
youtube en fait c'est pas que j'y
consacre peu de temps mais par rapport à
tous mes autres projets par rapport à
tout ce que je fais à côté est ce que je
faisais aussi avant c'est ça qui me
prend le moins de temps c'est pour ça
que quand tu dis aujourd'hui que 40 ou
sur youtube leur nom ce qui me prend le
plus de temps c'est le spectacle
écriture la tournée la promo donc ça
c'est comme avant ensuite l'écriture des
bouteurs tu vois j'ai sorti neuf truc en
librairie en un an et demi je suis
boulimique de création donc j'adore
faire ça donc je vais continuer mais je
n'aime pas l'idée qu'il faille
absolument choisir un truc et définir en
fait je suis un artiste au sens large et
je m'exprime sur des supports différents
avant c'était fou le spectacle
maintenance est toujours fou le
spectacle plus youtube ou clairement
j'adore faire ça plus les livres ou
clairement j'adore les écrire aussi donc
je vois pas pourquoi y en a un qui
prendraient trop l'ascendant sur l'autre
mais mais voilà ça je passerai pas ma
vie sur youtube c'est à dire à ne faire
que ça et parce que ce soit ma seule
activité
ça ça me rendrait malheureux parce qu il
me manquerait quelque chose le lien avec
le public
les trois choses principales que je vais
mettre en place je vais pas me faire
comme ça du jour au lendemain en fait
j'ai déjà commencé à les mettre en place
pour faire des tests sur vous et pour
voir comment vous pouviez accueillir les
choses alors la première chose
tout d'abord je vais utiliser la chaîne
fabien arrow post-it master qui était né
d'un délire en vraie chaîne secondaire à
partir de maintenant je vais poster les
choses dessus que je peux pas posté sur
la chaîne principale des choses trop
légères les trucs comme ça on va
retrouver un peu l'esprit de ma chaîne
celle-ci de la principale qui avait en
2016 tu vois donc ya pas de promesse à
peu pop et n'importe quand donc si vous
voulez vous abonner activer la cloche en
même temps pour être sûr de voir ce qui
se passe et on va retrouver un peu plus
du vrai moi qui suis vraiment avec le
même humour que j'ai sur scène avec tout
ce qui le passionne donc ça fait des
trucs sur cerveau mais ça peut être des
jeux des casse tête ça peut être du
mentalisme ça peut être aussi
d'astrophysique ça peut être du high
tech
voilà parce que je suis plus complexe
que juste le mec qui fait du mentalisme
et j'ai besoin de m'exprimer sur tous
ces sujets j'ai conscience que je peux
pas tout faire sur ma chaîne principale
donc ce sera là bas un autre espace de
liberté cette deuxième semaine sera donc
plus dans le fhaine vous avez
un lien au dessus de moi un lien dans la
description j'en mettrais à la fin de la
vidéo
si vous voulez me suivre là dessus c'est
très cool et si justement ça vous
intéressez pas ces sujets là vous serez
pas parasiter la deuxième chose ça
concerne un petit peu tout ce qui est
réseaux sociaux avec les fun fact des
jeux de l'esprit clair que ça s'est
tellement léger que même pour la chaîne
secondaire c'est pas possible de faire
une vidéo youtube avec tout ça donc j'ai
continué à mettre ça sur instagram
principalement vous avez vu ça depuis le
mois de décembre est apparemment vous
adorer ça et c'est très cool parce que
j'aime bien faire ça aussi donc je
continue tout ça et vous avez même pu
remarquer que je crée aussi du contenu
vidéo exprès pour instagram vous avez le
lien dans la description n'hésitez pas à
me suivre dessus si vous aussi vous êtes
sur instagram est alors si vous avez
facebook où il ya encore des gens qu'on
facebook et que vous me suivez si on
m'appelle je vous avez pu remarquer
quelque chose une nouveauté
j'ai fait 700 vidéos sur youtube depuis
que j'ai créé la chaîne est souvent dans
les commentaires des réseaux mais
principalement de youtube vous me
demandez de faire une vidéo sur un sujet
que j'ai déjà apprêté dans 7 700 vidéos
là donc j'ai pas le retraité et je peux
pas en permanence du gard j'ai déjà fait
cherche je vous ai déjà fait donc ce que
je vais faire
en fait j'ai déjà commencé à le faire
sur la fanpage je vais publier une vidéo
par jour mais il des anciennes vidéos
jusqu'à épuisement du stock donc tous
les jours je publie une des anciennes
vidéos qui peuvent vous intéresser
il ya 700 vidéos donc on est parti pour
plus de deux ans comme ça parce qu'il ya
les autres qui vont se rajouter si vous
êtes sur facebook
rajoutez ma fan belge ou mais également
un lien dans la description et vous
verrez ça passait tous les jours avec
peut-être des vidéos vous vous dirai à
mes j'avais pas vu ça et ça ça
m'intéresse et je savais pas qu'il avait
fait et vous la verrez passer encore une
fois sans parasites et la chaîne youtube
et pour la chaîne youtube sélectionné qu
elle veut continuer un petit peu comme
ça c'est à dire je vais continuer à
faire une vidéo par semaine minimum
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas remarqué nous
au mois de mars elle s'est fait quatre
vidéos au lieu de 10 g
roux commentaire sur le sujet et c'est
cool je me dis ok c'est que ce rythme là
ça vous convient exactement deux pas du
tout donc je vais continuer à faire une
vidéo par semaine au minimum
n'hésitez pas hâtive et la cloche parce
que des fois j'en fais un peu aussi
n'importe quand en plus je continue
également les lives sauvage et éphémère
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure la
seule chose la question que je me pose
c'est est ce qu'il faudrait pas mieux
les faire sur twitch j'hésite j'ai dit
j'ai dit j'hésite vraiment à faire ça
sur tweets mais j'ai pas trop d'avis sur
la question
dis toi dans les commentaires ce que
vous en pensez et je vous mets un
sondage ici dites moi sincèrement est-ce
qu'il vaut mieux les faire sur youtube
où vous préféreriez les voir sur twitter
et comme ça je prendrai ma décision en
fonction nous y avant de vous dire une
dernière chose fort importante je vais
répondre aux trois dernières questions
questions de wendy bus alias wendy parce
que vraiment on se connaît maintenant
avec wendy elle me suit depuis le tout
début de la chaîne un plateau d'artistes
comme vous le faites à cannes en avril
oui on fait un plateau le 17 avril avec
le lundi vix niçois ne périsse et céline
h max bird et moi il ya le lien pareil
sur mon site comme d'hab ou un peu comme
les analystes nation collective à paris
est il prévu à paris alors non j'ai rien
de prévu comme ça à paris avant de céder
ses hallucinations collectives c'est un
plateau que j'avais monté durant un an
et demi je faisais ça au grand point
virgule
j'habitais plein de gens des humoristes
des youtuber des gens qui avaient des
compétences spéciales et tous étaient
trop bien je le faisais une fois par
mois mais ça demande beaucoup de travail
à organiser certes à mettre en scène
aussi et après à communiquer en fait
c'est la com qui demande beaucoup
beaucoup de temps et si je communiquais
sur la chaîne je sais qu'à voir sa soul
ray tout le monde tu vois pas ce que
c'est spécifique à paris précisément
donc je remonte rien pour le moment
comme ça mais c'est pas dit que les
hallucinations reviennent pas un jour
les à me demande comment ça se fait
qu'on est revenu en arrière c'est parce
qu'on n'avait pas assez de profondeur
pour la vidéo est-ce qu'on peut te
demander de faire du col redding ou un
petit truc de mentalisme sur nous après
un dîner spectacle alors la réponse est
oui tu peux demander mais non je le
ferai pas pourquoi parce qu'en général
vous êtes 400-500 à m'attendre et dis
toi que je passe au minimum on va dire
le plus court 30 secondes par personne
fait le calcul et voit déjà combien de
temps ça prend donc faire un truc de
deux trois minutes par personne ça
prendrait beaucoup trop de temps et
j'essaie vraiment de voir tout le monde
n'y a pas une date où j'ai pas pu voir
tout le monde même à l'olympia vous
étudiez 900 attente j'ai vu les 900
personnes de fini à une heure du matin
mais je vous ai vu tous à part un juste
évidemment je peux pas faire un numéro à
tout le monde c'est pour ça que vous
avez deux heures de spectacle avant ça
et enfin julien qui dit d'après toi où
est la frontière entre le personnage et
la personne chez un mentaliste alors je
pense que c'est entre le personnage et
l'artiste ou entre la personne et
l'artiste est ce qu'il ya vraiment une
d'ailleurs la frontière à l'est allez
assez minces si ton personnage de scène
correspond au vrai toit par exemple pour
les patients dont je parle sur scène ce
sont mes vrais passionnés vrai truc sur
lequel j'ai des connaissances après je
mélange tout ça avec toutes les
techniques que ce soit de psychologie ou
d'illusionnisme pour en faire un show
donc dans la vie quotidienne non mais
forcément ce personnage là est vraiment
pas très éloignés l'un de l'autre
donc la frontière est mince et un peu
comme dans le film de prestige ce qui
consacre la vie à leurs secrets moi
c'est pas vraiment ça pour le coup mais
je consacre ma vie à ce qui me passionne
réellement même le spectacle singularité
cesseras trop physique parce que c'est
un truc qui me plaît donc la frontière
est effectivement très très minces
et puis c'est aussi la base du
mentalisme le mentalisme c'est une
discipline ambiguë par essence il faut
aller dans cette ambiguïté n'a porté le
mentaliste qui serait un peu choqué
d'une ambiguïté aurait tort parce que
dans ses prestations il est et imaginons
que son audience grandissent et bien
forcément l'ambiguïté va grossir avec
lui la frontière entre son personnage de
scène est la personne qu'il est dans la
vie vraiment sera toujours de plus en
plus minces par essence c'est l'essence
de cette discipline et c'est très cool
qu'on vit ensemble c'est vraiment
beaucoup trop cool
oui je sais c'est mon préféré il ya par
exemple donc la suite du spectacle où on
se retrouve toujours à chaque fois après
les spectacles des fois durant quelques
heures pour en discuter pour faire des
dédicaces tout ça et il ya la nouvelle
version du spectacle parce que la
tournée continue mais après il y aura la
nouvelle version on commence déjà à
ouvrir les dates pour la prochaine
saison il ya déjà lyon
quand il ya toulouse ya cinq villes en
belgique il ya une ville en suisse aussi
ou plusieurs et il ya même de fortes
chances que je sois au québec en août
cette année je vais me tenir au courant
de tout ça pour toutes ces dates vous
avez bien sûr le lien sur mon site
internet dans la description comme
d'habitude il ya aussi les livres qui
sont sortis traduit en six langues en
livre audio en livre de poche c'est d'un
lieu le la méthode de mémorisation
complète
je reçois tous les jours des messages
d'étudiants qui s'en servent et qui me
disent merci cca vous bravo de vous en
servir en fête et bravos de faire
confiance dans votre mémoire et je vous
cache pas que pour cette année là
l'année qui vient il ya encore trois
nouveaux gros projet je vous dit pas
lesquels
mais il ya un truc qui me fait vraiment
kiffé c'est d'être là où vous
m'attendais pas et à chaque fois de vous
surprendre quand je monte un projet
comme la chasse au trésor avec lady
véritable diamant a regagné quand je
monte ça je me dis mais ça va être ou
s'ils s'attendent tellement pas à ça et
ça c'est un vrai moteur c'est un peu
comme si je vous préparé des surprises
ou des blagues j'adore faire ça comme ça
merci à vous d'être ici continuer d'être
curieux continuez de vous intéresser à
plein de choses donner la chance aux
vidéos en cliquant sur la vignette même
qu'à vous plaît pas donné dix secondes
de chance à la vidéo pour voir si c'est
un sujet qui vraiment peut vous
intéresser ou pas pouvez vous abonner si
c'est pas fait évidemment mais ce serait
celle où si vous regardez cette vidéo
mais c'est pourquoi pas ça peut arriver
et puis voilà en fait restez comme vous
êtes vous êtes top
à très bientôt ciao